hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 1936 international
tournament in Moscow before we check out
the game and say something more about
the game and the tournament I did
prepare a nice for a challenge for you
it's it's something different than usual
but I do hope you enjoy it so best of
luck to everyone who are the two people
in this photo so you know no cheating
and best of luck to everyone and now
let's get back to the game so it's a
horrible couple Blanca versus go sleep
elise Casas now going into this round
first I did prepare here are all of the
games Mikhail Botvinnik played so you
all know that in the first in the first
half of the tournament was a roll kappa
blanka defeated Mikhail Botvinnik but
then as you can see ever since the
second half of the tournament that's
around 10 and and further botanique
really crushed the field he he achieved
five victories and four draws
unfortunately in the in the last round
against eleven fish with the black
pieces Botany could only achieve a draw
and that means that now he has the same
amount of winces Capablanca and
capablanca only needs a draw to win this
tournament so yes Capablanca with the
white pieces only needs the draw to win
the tournament that's you know that
sound like he okay he won the tournament
but every Elise Casas here is actually a
very strong player he's an Grandmaster
who represented Austria Germany and
Argentina in international competition
and also was considered as a potential
contender for the World Chess
Championship title and even though he
was considered to be the strongest
somewhere around 1930 1940s some 20
years 30 years after that in 1960 he
also defeated Bobby Fischer in Buenos
Aires so a very strong player and you
know even though okay come on Monica
does have the white pieces he still has
to play some good chess so let's see
let's see how he approaches the game
when he only needs a draw to win to win
the tournament
we have e4 e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and Bishop to c4 so the Italian game
Bishop to c5 we have the Joko piano a
Knight to c3 Knight to f6 D 3 d6 Bishop
to g5 and here Elise Casas goes for h6
for Cinco Blanca to either move the
bishop back or to capture on f6 if any
beginners are watching the you might get
the urge to you know keep on copying
White's moves but you can only do this
for for several more more moves for
example Knight to d5 you attack the
knight here twice if you copy it once
again an ID for then you get c3 and here
black is no longer able to copy moves if
you play c6 then you lose the game
horribly because you get to Knight
captures with Chuck G captures and after
you capture the knight pawn captures
Bishop and then after D captures on c5
you realize that white now has a bishop
and the night whereas black only has a
bishop so at some point you will not be
able to copy moves anymore so h6 now we
have Bishop captures on f6 Queen
captures on f6 couple uncle's mind
giving up the the bishop pair knife to
d5 attacking the Queen Queen has to go
back and now c3 a very nice move
controlling this night the night is
unable to go to b4 to d4 and also moves
like a B for a for and so on will be
possible in the future we have Knight to
e7 offering a trade of knights but 93
Capablanca goes back we have Bishop to
e6 Bishop captures pawn captures and now
Queen to b3 here kappa blanka attacks
the e6 pawn and also the b7 pawn only
way to defend this either Queen to d7 so
we sacrifice the b7 pawn but Ellis
causes simply plays Quinta CA to
defending both both points here we have
d4 pawn capture Sun B for C CAP net
Knight captures and before although C
captor Sundy 4 also is possible which
gives white a strong center but by
playing Knight captures on d4 cup of
vodka in fact forces yet another trade
of pieces so here's a double attack on
d6 pawn here forcing the black to
capture we have Bishop captures pawn
captures and now castles couple month
also castles and here we have Queen to
d7
seemingly offering the b7 pawn but
couple Blanca doesn't want to complicate
anything in fact you can in fact capture
it and after you're attacked with rook a
to b8 you have to go back you know
to capture the pond if you capture the
pond then yes you're gonna lose your
queen after Luke 2:8 Queen moves and
rook to b8 and now the queen is trapped
but after rook 88 you could go Queen a6
and then after black characters here
look to see one let's say and wife and
continue playing this game but you don't
want to ruin anything as you only need a
draw to win this tournament so after
Queen d7 simply rook to c1 rook to b8
basically forcing now black to defend on
b7 rook the c3 and here comes d5 first
Queen to c2 now with a double attack on
the c7 pawn we have c6 and now II five
locking the position rook to f4 now
Ellis casas would very much enjoy
doubling rooks on DF file Queen to d1
defending the d4 pawn as it was attacked
with a rugby - effect and now simply f3
Queen to d8 we have g3 kicking the room
back rook four - f7 and now f4 so white
it doesn't really have all that much
here yes he's controlling a bit more
space but you know he's quite happy he
would accept a draw if probably a fairly
scarce offered it at this point but as
Capablanca you know in his days he was
also known for something Carson is known
for it and in these days that you know
he wins a lot a lot of end games that
are actually drawn he will win them so
we have Knight to f5 Capablanca
exchanges Knight captures rook captures
and now h4 h4 because black was may be
planning g5 so you don't want to allow
any breakthroughs in the position H for
preventing g5 we have g6 now King to g2
and now Queen to e7 a3 not allowing
Queen to before Queen g7 now again
preparing g5 so rook to f3 now not
stopping g5 a queen back to e7
now comes Queen c2 King to g7 and now g4
here a cup of Blanca even goes goes for
something more than a draw you know as
there's nothing that can happen to him
rook to f7 and King to h3 simply
improving the position Queen to d7 we
have before now grabbing even more space
rock to g8 and now
rook to g1 King to h8 gnar comes Queen
to d2 Queen to d2 with ideas of f5 and
winning the h6 pawn with check so look
to h7 defending the pawn and now Queen
to f2 here again preparing f5 we have h5
and now comes G captures on h5 rook
captures on h5 and now rook to g5 here
Queen to h7 was played if you capture it
then after F captures white is
completely winning here rook f7 is
coming h5 is coming
there is nothing black can do here
anymore so here after loop to g5 Queen
to h7 was played and now Queen to g3
piling up on the g6 pawn but also
preparing Queen g4 with an attack on the
e6 pawn so Queen to h6 we have Queen to
g4 now attacking both pawns and now rook
to g7 so yet i mean kappa blanka cannot
capture here if you captured and rook
captures on h4 comes and now white will
no longer be able to push for anything
after King moves rook checks King moves
Queen comes here rook goes to g1 and
after here Queen h5 attacking the rook
on f3 now comes check and here for
example exchanging Queens and no no
sight can make any progress here so
after rook g7 we have worked to g3 now
you know keeping the tension up you know
simply piling up on that g6 pawn we have
king to h7 now defending the g6 point
three times and now rope the g2
preparing an escape path for the King we
have king to h8 and now comes King to g3
again you cannot capture here even
though the king is no longer defending
the pawn rook captures
would lose immediately to captures
captures and captures King moves and now
Queen captures and I for this is
checkmate
so I've talking to h8 we have King g3
our King moves back now you do have to
protect the Jesus exponent now we have
looked to h2 guarding the h4 pawn rook
to this rook to e7 now now you have to
guard the e6 pawn and now rook to h3
King to g7 now comes Luke captures on h5
here black doesn't really have a better
mood than King to g7
he could try to repeat with Queen g7 but
white would simply keep on increasing
pressure here he basically offers a
queen trade with King to g7 and
Capablanca goes for it we have rook
captures Queen captures Queen captures G
captures an age five and here it
certainly does seem like this is a
completely drawn and game but Ellis
causes missed one move a couple banker
made here so feel free to pause the
video and win this endgame for kappa
blanka and win the 1936 international
tournament in moscow so I will give it a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just won the
1936 international tournament in Moscow
and for those of you who just won't
enjoyed show here kappa blanka played f5
f5 is a quite a forcing move threatening
f6 to win the rookie mediately so you do
have to react to this you can't not
capture on f5 if f6 comes regardless of
it winning a rook you know that's the
past F pawn and you know you have to
capture it so Ellis causes this captured
but now you have came to f4 you've
created a nice route for a king to enter
deeper into the position so King to a4
and now rook to e6 giving up the f5
point but defending it is not much
better simply e6 is coming and now you
have two ways of getting your King into
the position Rocka faith in g5 and then
kingly 67 and the D pawn will win you
the game here after King f4 rook at 6
was played and now comes King captures
an f5 rub g6 trying to prevent Rob
jittery check but here comes East 6
rook g4 King comes v5 rock cap a rook
first checks
King this X and now rook captures on d4
here a couple Blanca simply played
rook to e3 and Eddie both with Alex
Casas resigned in the game why did he
resign well either you will move the
King and then King these seven wins or
you will try to block with the rogue
then captures captures and after any
move simply 7 King box King comes here
he ate well we knew the game so yeah
after op3
yet another victory for josé raúl
capablanca even
I mean he was better for the entire game
and perhaps God didn't it was cause it
didn't need to lose this but you know
it's it happens you know to the best of
them
so I did prepare something else here are
the final standings of the 1936
international tournament in Moscow we've
already seen them when I started the
series but you know as this is basically
finishing the series you know we can
check them out one more time so in first
place josé raúl capablanca with 13 out
of 18 8 wins 0 losses and 10 rows so a
perfect tournament basically make up
both Munich in second place 7 wins only
one loss to capablanca and 10 rows then
Solomon floor 5 wins 4 draws 9 losses
then under a lily on top of each Slovak
was in Emanuel Lasker grigory 11 fish
Eric Ellis cassis Ilya Bromwich Khan and
Nikolay Nikolayevich oh you mean the
person who so you know tragically
blundered is going to kappa blanka but i
mean he did beat kappa blanka in the
1935 tournament in moscow in the first
round so you know a lot of interesting
things happen in chess and ok that's
basically finishing this game I do hope
you enjoy it and I do hope you enjoy the
coverage of the entire tournament and I
did prepare something else to show you
so these are the results of the vote so
here you vote it for my next big series
as you can see 17,000 of you have voted
we have for the return match Crossan vs
Anand we have twenty four percent of
what votes are then for the 1927 and
match kappa blanka vs. aliens
bobby fischer story that's the intra
zonal tournament of palma de mallorca
plus candidates matches plus 1972 match
against Spassky 39 percent so definitely
the greatest and then with very few
votes the to Curto to versus Tiny's and
the first American chess congress of
course you don't know who won that one
so with 39 percent of votes our next big
series will be the Bobby Fischer story
I'm also very happy to you know go
through it like in in extreme detail the
you know further increase our vast
knowledge so that
actually makes me very happy but I will
not start it probably until next week as
I'm going to do Roenick on Friday and I
will only return somewhere around
Wednesday but I will I will post a
couple of videos while I'm in Dubrovnik
so you know no fear not so yeah that's
it just wanted to inform you of that and
yeah I do hope you enjoyed everything as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully
perhaps with another miniseries until
Friday or maybe maybe with just some
other interesting videos thank you